hello all and welcome to khan academy
for parents 6th through 8th grade remote
learning webinar
i'm megan patani i lead u.s professional
learning here at khan academy and i'm
joined today by two of my wonderful
colleagues roy chan who's a member of
our us district partnership team and he
works with teachers and communities all
over the u.s and dan too who's our
director of marketing and he's also
working with families and communities to
help you know instill best practices for
remote learning
what we'll cover today is how you can
keep your children learning during
school closures and some best tips and
practices for setting up a daily
schedule for students to use khan
academy
one note of what we won't be covering
today is account setup or how to get
started
this webinar is not going to walk
through how to set up an account for you
or for your student so if you're looking
for more information on how to get
started with khan academy please see our
remote learning quick start guide and
these slides and all the resources that
go along with them can be found in the
handout on the right hand side of your
go to webinar panel
just as a quick note that khan academy
is free trusted and flexible we're a
non-profit with a mission to provide a
free world-class education
for anyone anywhere
we have standards aligned practice and
lessons covering k-12 math grammar
science computer programming history ap
courses official sad practice and a lot
more
and your students are able to learn on
the web or on our app through ios or
android at any time anywhere in over 40
languages
so what type of content is available in
addition to full coverage for math our
content library also includes things
like american history computer animation
and programming grammar growth mindset
which is built in collaboration with
perts at stanford high school biology
and storytelling which is created in
partnership with disney and pixar
so where would students find content
or where would you find content by
clicking the left hand courses menu on
the top left of the khan academy site
you'll have access to our entire content
menu
or you can select edit courses from the
student's home page to access content
and then click continue
the content that's originally suggested
to your student will be based off the
grade level they selected when they set
up their account
so let's talk a little bit about daily
schedules for 6th through 8th graders
khan academy has been sharing school
closure schedules for students across
grade levels but we're going to be
focusing on what we think of as a middle
school range in the us our sixth through
eighth grade students and here is a
quick overview of what we recommend
the areas covered in green are going to
be the areas that we focus on a little
bit more during this webinar these are
what we think of as academic areas in
the day
so starting in the morning
we recommend the students get up get
dressed yes actually get out of their
pjs and then focus on their math skills
one of the reasons we recommend that is
that students and teachers have said
they feel like their brain is ready to
work and that they're energized and able
to work on math more effectively in the
morning now definitely feel free to
adapt this to you or to your students
but again this is a recommend
recommendation for many of our teachers
and students that they feel like the
morning is the best time for them to
focus on math and based on your child or
students grade level we recommend one of
the following math courses as a good
place to start sixth seventh or eighth
grade math algebra one or geometry
if you feel like you're a student you're
not quite sure where they should start
and then you want to put them on grade
level but you know that they already
know some of the material they can use
course challenges and unit tests to
accelerate through material quickly
all of our math content is mastery
enabled and it covers standards from
kindergarten through early college it
includes instant feedback step-by-step
solutions like you're seeing on the
screen right now that students can
select a hint and see a step-by-step
workthrough of that exact problem
it also offers instruction in the form
of videos and articles practice first
single skill in the form of exercises or
assessments in the form of quizzes unit
tests and course challenges
all the while tracking progress at the
skill unit and course level for students
after math time we recommend students
get out and go for a walk or run if the
weather is bad try something like just
dance find a reason to get up and get
moving
then maybe take some time to read khan
academy has compiled a list of books for
6th through 8th graders if you click on
that link you'll see specifically what
those recommendations are from our
teacher and community
again take a short break it's really
easy for students to get caught up in
wanting to do all the work that they
have but it's important that students
get up from their screens and are able
to move around
then we recommend jumping into some
english language arts
while we have a full grammar course and
it may say third through fifth grade on
the content we've seen students from
kindergarten through high school benefit
from working on our grammar course
if maybe that doesn't appeal to your
student try our storytelling course
our grammar course like our math courses
is mastery enabled it covers over a
hundred grammar skills and similar to
our math courses it has instant feedback
step-by-step solution instruction in the
form of videos and articles practice and
assessments
similar to our math courses if you feel
that your student is able to accelerate
quickly through some of the material
have them engage with unit tests and
course challenges and they'll be able to
move through that material quickly and
then focus their time on skills they may
need more practice with
we also have some new beta content for
ela which covers standards in second
through eighth grade reading and
vocabulary what this means is this is an
early version of some new content that's
coming for each grade level and it's
broken out for second third fourth fifth
sixth seventh and eighth grade so you
can have your student practice on
specific grade level appropriate
questions including instant feedback and
work rationales for every question
and the passage topics are grade
appropriate in areas of science social
studies and social emotional learning
to supplement our ela content students
are also encouraged to engage with our
imagineering in a box course which is
created in partnership with disney
this allows for project-based learning
and for students to get a little more
creative
it includes things like the
behind-the-scenes look at how artists
designers and engineers work together to
create disney parks it includes
instruction aspects of videos and
articles and project-based activities to
design their own theme park
after lunch we recommend that students
engage in some science and our social
studies our science courses allow
students to look at things like what is
a virus and how might the human body
respond to that or look at our history
courses to align maybe some historical
aspects that align with things that are
currently happening in the news or how
countries are responding to the pandemic
our high school biology course like our
math and grammar course is master
enabled covering introductory level
biology topics including areas that are
middle school age appropriate it
includes instant feedback and work
rationale for every question instruction
in the form of videos and articles
practice exercises and assessments in
terms of quizzes unit tests and course
challenges
our us history course is also mastery
enabled
excuse
me it includes instant feedback
instruction and practice just like our
other mastery enabled courses
in the very end of the afternoon what
students would think of as the normal
end to their school day we encourage
students to engage in some enrichment
content
things like maybe code.org express force
or khan academy's computer programming
or growth mindset content
our computer animation course is an
interactive course that demonstrates how
traditional school subjects such as math
science and the art are a vital part of
everyday work put into pixar's
filmmaking process for many students
this answers the question of why am i
doing this and our interactive units
range from the art of lining to set in
staging so it allows students to apply
the concepts that they're learning in
their academic courses into something in
the real world
again they receive instant feedback
step-by-step solution instruction and
practice
finally our growth mindset content
provides a structured way for students
to explore the idea that they in fact
can learn anything it includes units on
the brain and learning working through
frustration and making and learning from
mistakes and setting goals it includes
instruction in the form of videos and
articles for students and also includes
teacher resources that you as a parent
can use to help guide your student
through these growth mindset activities
if you're looking for more tips and best
practices for remote learning
we also have some resources around seven
tips for effective remote learning to
help support students teachers and
parents during this time
now we know many of you have questions
and we're going to take the time now to
go through those questions as i hand it
over to dan but please feel free that if
we don't get to your question or if you
have additional ones to reach out to our
help center where we have answers to
frequently asked questions as well as a
community space
thank you megan hi everyone i'm dan and
i'll be moderating the live uh portion
of this q a and i wanted to give a shout
out to roy for manning the submitted
questions um before we kind of get into
the live section as megan said we have a
limited amount of time so we're not
going to get to everybody but rest
assured afterwards um the team does look
over the questions and we try to surface
the ones that are really important that
are and that are frequently asked and we
do update those documents as we go along
so the two steps that we'd ask you to
follow before we go to the live step
live question portion is
first go out to the handout sections of
this presentation and grab
the download it contains guidance
through everything that megan just
walked through between an overview of
the available content for middle
schoolers to the suggested schedules and
the framework and you can always modify
those to meet your needs as well as many
of you have seen links throughout the
presentation and so you'll have links to
all those resources as well and then a
second thing i'd ask if you have any
questions please put them in the
question box now
and i'll do the facilitating while megan
actually does the hard work of answering
the questions
all right
so we have quite a few questions already
coming in we have one that actually i
can answer first which is is the
suggested reading list available on the
site someplace so right now
in the daily schedules we do have some
lists of recommended reading recommended
books we are early next week going to
have a separate page with an updated
reading list organized by category so
come back on probably tuesday or
wednesday and we'll have that available
for you all
so megan we have a question from
jacqueline who asks what does mastery
enabled course content mean on slide two
i think that's a fantastic question
and we get that question a lot
yeah thanks dan jacqueline that is a
really common question and a really
important one so
bear with me this is going to take a
minute to go over so when we think about
khan academy and the way we encourage
students to learn we're really founded
in the principles of mastery learning
that students learn at their own time
and pace if given the right content that
fits their needs and so that students
can either you know fill in gaps in
areas that they might have struggled
with or misleading in the past and can
also accelerate ahead to areas that
they're really strong in
and so
because khan academy is founded in this
belief of mastery learning
our courses that are mastery enabled and
we're working to bring even more of our
courses to be what we call mastery
enabled
it allows students to see specifically
how they're doing
in each individual skill
the unit and the entire course
by using those practice exercises and
assessments in the form of quizzes tests
and course challenges
students move from not started to
attempted to familiar to proficient and
mastered and all those levels mean is
how well the student is demonstrating
their understanding of an individual
skill and so for students to achieve
those high level of mastery they have to
be able to demonstrate their
understanding of a skill in multiple
ways and so when we say a course is
mastery enabled it means it has all of
these pieces that allows a student to
learn at their own pace and to
demonstrate their understanding
so that they are able to understand
areas where they may need more support
or areas where they're ready to move
ahead
great so megan this is kind of just
pretty related so a question from yvette
asks if my children are in a gate
program a gifted and talented education
program how would i determine which
courses are best for them and i think
this is
a question whether uh your child is in
an advanced state or if your child needs
some remediation in a specific subject i
think it's relevant for for multiple
audiences
yeah you're absolutely right and this is
a question we get you know
obviously for gifted and talented
students but i think for all students
parents you're being asked a really
tough challenge right now
where does my students start at the
moment
right this has been something that your
teachers have been working with your
students all year but now you're kind of
dropped into the middle and so
our first recommendation is look for
guidance from teachers if the teachers
have provided specific guidance on where
the student might already be working
definitely leverage that so if you know
your student is in you know an algebra
course and they're part of the way
through
i would we would recommend looking at
the algebra course and then taking the
course challenge and what the student
does is they get a mixed review of
questions and it'll highlight very
quickly areas for the student to work on
and areas that they already know the
content
if you don't have a good idea of where
your student might be
based on email either feedback from the
teacher or the course you know they're
registered for
then you can either a look at something
like grade level content so our courses
for math in particular are broken out by
grade level so if you had a sixth grade
student we might recommend that you
start them on sixth grade
or you can start them a grade behind if
you feel like you know that there's a
lot of gaps for them
the other alternative is to look at some
of our courses that cover from a couple
of different grade levels so things like
arithmetic um
cover multiple grade levels and give
students kind of a better idea where
they might fall but again i would circle
back to if you have recommendations from
your teachers they know your students
really well so i would start there and
then recommend on grade level if you
feel like your student needs to step
back or move ahead again they can use
those components of the course itself to
either spend more time on specific
learning using videos and articles and
then engaging with the practice or if
you feel like they're really strong they
can accelerate quickly by using the unit
tests or the course challenges
and i would just add megan that it
doesn't hurt to review materials that
that your child's already um you know
already proficient in and in fact one of
our uh teacher educators tim tim
vandenberg recommends for his class he
starts everyone at kindergarten level
and just have them quickly roll through
the the course and really hit there so
that they can progress and kind of fill
in the swiss cheese gaps that they have
and so everyone kind of really learns at
their own pace
that's great dan and we find with
teachers and we think at the beginning
of the year we often encourage them to
engage with something similar so that
students can build confidence in using
khan academy with something they already
know before they get into challenging
material so i think that's a really
great recommendation dan
so megan we have a question from matilda
who asks for the math program do you
remember do you recommend the students
start with the unit test or quiz before
they do the practice first just to see
what they already know or just start
from top to bottom but doing the
practices and go down the list
sure i think it's it's a little bit of
preference
um some students really prefer to build
up their confidence with this individual
skills first and then go to the unit
test because the unit test will cover
all the skills in the unit and that can
be really intimidating for students
however in this unique situation that
we're in right now if you're not sure
where to start with your students or
they think they might know part of it
then if you're not sure where the
student should start i would recommend
starting with the course challenge or
the unit test so to help the student
identify what they should focus on if
they already know what unit they are
working in then i might recommend going
from top to bottom because it's designed
for students to build confidence and
build skills on top of each other so
that they feel really confident and can
make great progress
great and so megan this
these next series of questions one from
lillian and one from mita i i think all
parents are asking this question is
really around like how much parental
assistance uh would you you know
recommend or would you say is required
um to help your child through these
courses
so i think that's a really tough
question
um so first of all
we all know you're doing double or
triple duty right now right being a
full-time parent and a full-time
employee and now a full-time teacher so
one we're definitely not expecting you
to know all of the content for your
students math course or science course
or computer programming whatever it is
they're using khan academy for
um
well we do find that if you want a
little more content knowledge we're
finding a lot of parents find it really
kind of challenging exciting to learn
alongside their student um and i was a
classroom teacher for nine years and i
can say that one of the most exciting
things for my students was to admit like
you know what i don't know the answer to
that why don't we work through it
together so if you're looking to give
support don't be afraid to engage with
your students say you know what i don't
remember how to multiply fractions like
that's totally fine you know it gives
you an opportunity to show them you know
you never stop learning and something to
learn with them
the idea with the schedules i think to
address that question a little more
directly is the schedules are designed
to help the students stay on pace but
they're still going to need support from
someone else and so khan academy while a
wonderful tool is not meant to replace
the teacher entirely and so we do
recommend that there is some support
given to the student as they work
through this so if you can encourage
your student to work within that
schedule or maybe take time to you know
discuss the reading you're doing
together and maybe some of that
recommended reading so it is meant to be
used
with you know
parent or guardian or some sort of
supporting figure along with them um
though we would think at the middle
school age level they would be able to
follow a great majority of this by
themselves
yeah and i would just add on to that uh
megan like i think where the parents
where you as parents are particularly
useful in this case is is to help
provide structure for your learners i i
don't think you know it's been a while
since i've done any geometry or algebra
so it's it's not like we expect you to
remember how to do differential
equations off the top of your head i
think it's more about helping the
schedule and helping to motivate your
child and providing that level of
support versus actual subject expertise
that's excellent
um so megan we have a question around
would you mind [ __ ] from diane would you
mind sharing where we can find the
course challenge in order to end it in
order to identify where the learning
gaps and successes are
sure no problem
so i'm actually going to
move over to the khan academy site and i
believe you all should be able to see my
screen in just a minute
and so i think this is a really
important question because we do often
offer this as guidance if you don't know
where your student should start they can
take the course challenge and so let's
take algebra one for example
if i'm a student and i select courses in
the top left of my site
i can see all the courses that are
available to me as a student and then
let's say i'm going to take algebra 1
and i choose algebra 1 from the course
list
this will bring me to the course page
for algebra and shows me all of the
content that's available
if i scroll all the way down to the
bottom of the page
you'll see this box that says course
challenge
and here if i click start course
challenge
it'll pop up with
excuse me 30 questions that are on
skills throughout the course and so
here i'll be offered again 30 questions
that cover a variety of skills
throughout the entire course we do
expect this to take most students 30 to
45 minutes to complete so this is where
you feel like is the best place for your
student to start make sure they have
enough time to do so and i would also
recommend that they have a couple of
tools with them things like pencil and
paper or a whiteboard because they're
probably going to need some space to
work through those problems
and then once they complete the course
challenge it'll show them in the results
some skills that they're really strong
with and some skills where they might
need some more support and what will
happen in the course itself is they'll
have indicators with kind of little
sparkly star marks of areas for them to
focus on so students know after they
take the course challenge within khan
academy itself they'll know where to
focus their time
[Music]
great
so um here's a question that actually i
can answer so a question from lauren and
the question is how should i use this
supplement uh and what uh i guess how
should i use this as a supplement to
what our school district is giving and
um in terms of uh how to use this so we
sorry we created um the these schedules
uh
early on in this process before others
were made available and so we were
really trying to fill a void uh that we
saw that was existed out there um we
would say recommend you defer defer to
your school district's recommendations
first and actually really modify this to
fit your needs as well so if there are
gaps that you feel like you want your
child to follow do that but this by no
means is meant to kind of override what
your school district or your school
is advising
great question though um so megan we
have a question from vivian who asks hi
i'm the mother of an eighth grader who's
quarantined at home right now
i'd like to know what good strategies i
can use to help my child stay motivated
in learning she's sloppy
with her schoolwork because most of the
assignments is not mandatory
yeah i think this is something that
is not exclusive to parents right now
we're seeing this with a lot of our
teachers it's um first of all middle
school is really hard
and it's hard to keep students motivated
even in the classroom let alone now that
they're you know working remotely and
then you as a parent are trying to
instill in them the you know commitment
to still learning when they're not in
the physical brick and mortar space
and so some things we're finding are
motivating are um you know with students
either sharing maybe that connection to
what things that are they're learning
are to you know greater things in life
so in some of our careers or some of the
imagineering resources you know
showcasing connections for students um
one of the more external ones that we're
finding teachers are doing this but i
think it's applicable to anyone is that
finding ways to motivate their students
um in things like doing challenges or
little fun videos or fun activities that
maybe where are outside even your own
comfort zone to get students and say you
know if you're willing to make 10
progress in seventh grade math if you
make that progress i as your parent will
um you know
let you as a you know parent let you
paint my fingernails green or you know
things that you can't necessarily buy
but might be really funny so we've seen
a teacher for example do the tick tock
flip
where they you know their daughter was
putting on makeup and then he changes
and he's putting on the makeup instead
and so just funny little things that are
again that are really appealing to your
student or your child um that again it's
not necessarily even like bribery per se
but something that's really creative or
something like that that might engage
them to say like oh i'm putting in this
effort and you're putting in the effort
with me to do so
the other thing that i'll circle back to
that we talked about earlier that we
find is motivating for students is a
someone willing to learn alongside them
so again that idea that we we definitely
wouldn't expect you to remember all of
your geometry or seventh grade math
but that you're open with your student
and saying why don't we learn this
together why don't we go back and learn
something together or if you learn your
math maybe we'll sit down and try this
intro to javascript class together and
learn something new together so making
it something that you are doing as you
know a family as opposed to something
that the student has to do in isolation
great thank you we have uh two questions
that are kind of related around the
breadth and extents of extent of our
content so deborah asks um
do your grade level classes cover an
entire
year's worth of questions and then kind
of related to that marcy's asking you
know once their child completes all of
the eighth grade course challenges will
khan academy automatically kind of move
them up to the next level
so when we talk about breadth and depth
of our content we do most of the courses
are expected to take a full year so if
you're looking at a full math course
like sixth seventh or eighth grade math
that is expected to cover all of the
skills or the great majority of skills
that are in that course according to
common core state standards so all of
our courses are common core state
standard align and the breadth of that
is you know what is expected for that
course completion
so the answer to that is yes it's
supposed to take that that long and we
when we have teachers work on things
like setting a goal for students on what
they would expect to complete for the
year we expect them getting to 80 or 90
of mastery would be what we would expect
student to accomplish in a whole year so
i wouldn't expect your student to
complete all of seventh grade math in
the next three weeks that seems like a
really big like unattainable ask
and um
so i'm sorry again what's the second
part of that question again so the
question is once you know it the first
part was do we have enough to cover the
whole school year which is the answer is
yes the second question is if their
child does complete kind of the whole
grade
all of eighth grade for example do they
automatically move on to the next level
great so students are encouraged to go
to the next level however students have
access to all of the content at all time
so if students are working on let's say
seventh grade content and they see that
they are struggling on particular skills
we they have the opportunity to go back
and look at the you know foundational
skills for that in sixth grade or fifth
grade and they can access that content
at any time the same thing is true for
moving ahead so while they when they
finish seventh grade they're encouraged
to move to eighth grade it won't the
program won't force them to do so but
they're encouraged to go to eighth grade
and they could continue to go to you
know algebra one and geometry so that
they have access to the entire library
of content at any time anywhere
so that once students complete one thing
they're able to move on to something
else so they never run out of content to
study
yep and just as much as they can advance
for it if they feel like they're they
they need to remediate something in the
past they can always look at you know
last year's content as well and do that
type of review
um so megan i think we have time for one
more question and a lot of parents are
interested in this so jennifer asks is
there a way to follow the child's
progress
remotely so
very important question and we yes
and so there's a couple ways you can do
that but we recommend you create a
parent account and then you can link
your parent account to your child's
student account and you can follow their
progress so you can know what they're
working on how much time they're
spending on it and what progress they're
making and so
for more information on that again while
we didn't cover it in this webinar it's
included in the slides is a link to our
parent quick start guide and that will
walk you through how to set up a parent
account and you can connect that to your
student or if you have more than one
child students and you're able to follow
their progress and their learning
experience on khan academy
perfect
well thank you megan for sharing your
expertise with our audience
and then thank you our audience for
taking the time out of your busy evening
to be with us
we know you're extremely busy during
this period of time and we really
appreciate you investing your time into
this session as we mentioned at the
start of this if you uh we didn't have
time to answer your questions
don't worry we'll you know follow up in
terms of an faq and whatnot and if you
missed something i want to review we
will be posting recording of this
webinar as well as the presentation that
you that you saw here and make it
available online for those of you who
registered for this webinar um
you know you will automatically be
emailed this information if you know of
other people who would be interested in
this information please go to khan
academy.org and you can always share out
the links to friends and family who
might be interested as well
and before we
kind of sign off i wanted to mention
that we were able to do this uh webinar
as a result of some
terrific partners bank of america
google.org at t and novartis who really
is really stepping up and helping us
make resources like this available to
you all
and then um before we sign off we ask
one more favor of you all so first if
at the end of this presentation a pop-up
will appear and we asked that if you
could provide us feedback on how to make
future iterations of this session even
better for you all
and then secondly we asked feedback on
what kind of sessions you'd like to hear
next um we created this session actually
as a response and feedback from our
first high-level presentation where many
of you asked for more specifics around a
schedule as well as how to find content
and so rest assured we are definitely
listening to your feedback and we
definitely want to create more valuable
resources for you and
we're here to support you
so in closing we just wanted to
recognize that you're juggling a lot
right now both as parents as educators
um as well as working adults and this is
really uncharted territory for all of us
and so we here at khan academy just want
to remind you to be kind to yourselves
um it's okay to miss one thing or
another um and we're here to help you
sin we just know that you've got this
so from all of us at khan academy thanks
again and good night